hey Vsauce Michael here and today I
released a brand new Vsauce Leanback a
playlist of educational videos from all
over YouTube that I think are cool and I
host sort of like a Vsauce TV show you
can start that by clicking the box up in
the corner or the link at the top of
this video's description but before that
I want to talk about the Shepard tone
it's a sound made out of multiple sine
waves that play a trick on us see what
they do is continuously rise in pitch
and then every so often one of them
drops down an octave but our brains
don't perceive that because the other
two continue rising and cover for it the
sine waves take turns dropping down an
octave producing a sonic barber pole a
noise that appears to keep rising and
pitch forever and ever without ever
actually going anywhere
I was reminded of it this week by
falling falling calm a creation of
Internet artists new Raphael where the
shepherd tone seems to go down and fall
forever
Raphael also made some other cool sites
like out in the wind calm here
there's nothing except for this menacing
wind that slowly erodes your cursor okay
now some of you may already know this
but in America we say adidas whereas the
rest of the world says ah DDoS and no it
does not stand for all day I dream about
soccer that's just a backronym an
acronym made up for a word that already
exists instead it's named after a person
which is why people pronounce it a DDoS
it's named after Adi Dassler a German
guy who got in a fight with his brother
so his brother rudolf went across the
river and started his own athletic
company known as puma that's right
Adidas and Puma came from the same town
from the same family finally before the
Leanback I want to share this USB
typewriter with you it's a really cool
device that plugs into your computer and
works like a normal keyboard except at
the same time it keeps a hard copy for
your records
it even works with an iPad alright now
it's time to watch Vsauce Leanback you
can click here to start it I'll meet you
over there
and as always thanks for watching